after a mysterious unnamed virus takes
out every human being philip miller is
the last man on earth he has been living
alone for the past year and is driving
around america to look for more people
he goes to every single state making
announcements to empty cities and
stealing artifacts and paintings from
museums after the failed mission to find
humans philip decides to return to his
hometown tucson still at the last
attempt to find someone he writes alive
in tucson on every billboard he can find
in tucson he goes to his shabby
apartment and packs up all the necessary
stuff before making his way to a gated
community in the more lavish part of the
city he chooses the biggest house and
declares it as his new home he spends
the next few days decorating the house
with all the famous paintings a mat from
the white house a dinosaur skull academy
awards and many more artifacts worth
billions of dollars nicholas cage would
be proud every day before going to sleep
philip makes sure to apologize to god
for masturbating so much and wishes that
he sees the face of at least one woman
before his death thankfully there are
still a plethora of cars that he can use
to drive around he goes to the grocery
store in his underwear and breaks in
using a gun in only a year he has
completely forgotten basic decency now
that he has no one to impress he also
does everything that was just an
impulsive thought before the virus like
destroying the pile of cans in the store
and bringing hundreds of adult films
home to pass time he plays racquetball
with himself uses lamps and aquariums as
bowling pins and crashes cars into each
other the chaos makes him feel a hint of
adrenaline and helps him cope with the
loneliness after about a month he starts
to lose his sense of sanity moreover
being alone on his birthday reminds him
of everything he failed to appreciate
when life was normal he misses his
mother his life and humans in general
the scene cuts to a few months later the
grand mansion philip lived in has turned
into a dumping site it is filled with
plastic and cans that he never cleans up
because there won't be a meaning to it
anyway he hasn't showered in days and
has started living like an animal the
house lacks running water and the toilet
is covered in plastic bottles so instead
philip makes a hole in the springboard
and uses the pool as his toilet he also
fills a kid's pool with margaritas and
bathes in it while simultaneously
drinking from it let's hope he never
gets the two pools confused then one day
he goes to the bar and draws faces on
balls assigning them names and
personalities he talks to them like
they're his real friends just to feel
like he isn't lonely at night he brings
a ball named gary to a clothing store
and hits on a mannequin that he has a
crush on when her arm breaks philip
loses his mind he decides that he
doesn't want to live anymore and goes to
the nearby hill to commit the
unthinkable he wishes farewell to all of
his ball friends promising to remember
them for eternity then he gets inside
his car and drives towards the hill at
full speed suddenly he sees smoke rising
far away and stops the car seconds
before it crashes philip can almost not
believe his eyes he immediately follows
the smoke and reaches a trailer that is
clearly inhabited by a person then he
notices something he had been begging to
see for the past year someone has left
their bra to dry in the sun philip
smells it and is so overwhelmed that he
falls unconscious when he wakes up he
sees a beautiful girl holding him in her
lap she seductively promises to fulfill
his wishes and kisses him philip is
enjoying the kiss before he wakes up and
realizes he was dreaming the girl in
front of him is less attractive and
older she is performing cpr on him to
bring him back they pull away from each
other weirded out upon seeing another
human after so long philip asks her
where the beautiful woman is until she
points out he should be worried about
his wet underpants instead it turns out
that he peed himself when he was
unconscious even in a situation like
this philip claims that he was swimming
from the front side earlier which is why
his underpants are wet he aggressively
starts explaining that he did not pee
himself which makes the girl panic she
brings out a gun asking him to stay away
philip finally admits that he did in
fact pee and is embarrassed after both
of them calmed down they introduced
themselves the girl's name is carol she
used to be an analyst before the virus
and has been wandering around america
after everyone died she saw the alive in
tucson sign and came here to see if she
really is the last person alive although
philip had been dying to meet a woman he
isn't very excited to see carol she
repeatedly corrects his grammar doesn't
understand his jokes and keeps talking
about irrelevant things after talking
for a while they decide to drive to the
grocery store on the way carol complains
about him crossing the stop sign despite
philip arguing that there is no traffic
she remains adamant that they have to
follow the rules or else they will start
living like animals to make her feel
better he stops at a sign and looks to
both sides confirming that no one is
crossing the road her nagging doesn't
stop when they reach the grocery store
and philip parks in the handicapped spot
they get into their fifth argument of
the day with philip insisting that this
imaginary handicapped person has a lot
of space to park his car when carol
still urges him to park somewhere else
he runs the vehicle straight into the
store following that she goes to take a
tour of his house and is disgusted by
the way he lives he has two swimming
pools one filled with feces and the
other with garbage carol also accuses
him of stealing the paintings even
though he argues they didn't belong to
anyone anymore by the end of the house
tour philip asks her to go back to her
campsite the next morning he is woken up
by carol cleaning up his house she nags
him to get gardening and cleaning
supplies from the store because they
have to start living like human beings
at night philip goes to his ball buddies
and complains about carol even though he
has only known her for a day he feels
like they are a married couple who
desperately need to get a divorce the
following morning things get worse for
him as she moves into the house next
door he tries to shoe her away but carol
being carol is stubborn she asks him if
he is scared of being seen naked and as
a reply phillip takes off his pants
carol finally addresses the elephant in
the room and brings up the topic of
reproduction she thinks that they are
the chosen ones who have been given the
duty to repopulate the earth philip says
he wouldn't sleep with her even if she
was the last woman on earth which is
true in this case in the next scene he
is in his outdoor toilet when carol
approaches him she wants him to find a
way to get running water to their house
that way they can grow tomatoes and
other fruits when he refuses to help she
tries to bribe him with fresh tomatoes
but he doesn't care she should know
better than to try bribing a guy who
poops off a diving board however when it
gets dark he breaks into her garden and
eats all of her vegetables carol knocks
on his door the next morning and finds
him covered in leftover tomatoes philip
still claims that he isn't the one who
stole them he also notices carol has
hurt her leg while trying to transfer
water to her house from a manhole a few
days later she gives up on trying to
live like a decent human philip finds
her making an outdoor toilet in a
fountain copying his swimming pool
toilet carol thinks that they might not
be the chosen ones but instead the
forgotten ones who have no purpose in
life they are in no way capable of
creating an entire human civilization
when they cannot even arrange a toilet
in their million dollar mansions philip
who is used to seeing carol as an
optimistic person feels awful for her
hence he goes to the city's water tank
and arranges a way to water carol's
garden she is finally happy to see a
good side to him and invites him for
dinner at night philip enjoys an organic
meal after a long time the topic of sex
is brought up and phillip says he is
ready to sleep with her now however to
his surprise carol doesn't want to make
love before marriage initially philip
laughs thinking that it is a joke but
she turns out to be serious even though
the idea is ridiculous he proposes to
make her feel better at last they decide
to get married the next day in the
following scene they are in church
saying their vows philip thinks it isn't
necessary but goes with the act anyway
when they step out of the church they
are welcomed by a crowd of guests philip
realizes he has made a mistake and
screams then he wakes up on his bed
thankful that it was only a dream he
even has to check out the window to
ensure that most of the world is still
dead a while later carol comes to his
house with food she thinks they should
elect the president of the united states
by voting it is useless but philip
elects himself and becomes the president
unanimously then the two enjoy spaghetti
and raisin balls which carol thinks is a
good alternative to meatballs following
that the day of the wedding finally
comes carol prepares the decorations in
cake while philip is tasked to get rings
for them however instead of getting the
rings he throws a bachelorette party for
his ball buddies setting fire to random
things in a parking lot he even goes to
say goodbye to the mannequin telling her
that she will always remain the love of
his life at the end of the day he goes
to the church where carol has prepared a
recording that will officiate their
wedding after brief vows it is finally
time to exchange rings this is when
carol discovers that he didn't get them
she realizes she is the only one putting
effort and calls off the wedding later
philip knocks on her door trying to talk
to her but she doesn't reply hence he
breaks down the front door with a hammer
and enters the house to his surprise she
is actually put in an effort to decorate
it she has even prepared a cake for them
with his statue on top philip feels
awful about what he did and apologizes
to her he also reveals that he doesn't
really like her personality or the food
she cooks but even so he is glad that
she exists because without her he would
not be alive right now with that being
said philip brings her out to do
something special in the following scene
they go to a jewelry shop where carol
gets all the rings she wants they
finally officiate the wedding and are
declared husband and wife at night the
two make love but the experience is not
how philip thought it would be carol
cannot stop talking throughout the night
making strange remarks that she thinks
are hot the next morning she finds him
playing racquetball in his home philip
thinks she is going to nag him again but
to his surprise she joins him in the
game they enjoy the rest of the day
doing things like philip normally does
they make fire proof suits and set each
other on fire run a bulldozer over beer
cans and go to meet philip's
ex-girlfriend who is a mannequin carol
talks to her for a while before beating
her up for hitting on her husband for
the first time philip is glad that he
married her and thinks that their life
might be tolerable as they are driving
back home they suddenly hit a limo in a
junction shocked philip runs to the car
and sees a beautiful woman come out of
it just when he thought he was happy
with his wife he starts to regret their
marriage to know what happens to them
next watch the second part on our new
channel series recapped